turkey has stepped up efforts to clear
the rubble three weeks after two
devastating earthquakes equipment has
been sent to the affected areas as they
are now concerns about People's Health
let's go straight to our correspondent
Theresa Beau who is live in gazingtep in
southern turkey a Teresa we know the
Turkish government has been under a lot
of pressure to provide help for the
people living in this part of the
country there is need for a lot of
things what is the situation where you
are what are you seeing are people
getting the help they need
well I am in the center of gazian's Hep
this is a plaza where you can see
there's dozens and dozens of tents with
people living in them and wherever you
go in Southeastern turkey this is the
image that you see right now tense all
over the place with hundreds of
thousands people who have been displaced
either their homes were completely
destroyed or they're too afraid to go
back to their homes because they have
been damaged and the aftershocks that
are still ongoing are scaring the
population we have to be talking to to
these people all around this area and
what they're telling us is that they
have gotten some tents that they have
some food that they have some water that
it's difficult to be on the outdoors in
the middle of winter but they're
struggling but they're also telling us
that some of them have received some
government assistance the Turkish
government has been handing out around
500 among those affected we know that
one million people have already got that
money this is something to help help
them the government is hoping to put
together also a rebuilding plan we're
building around 200 000 homes in the
next year it's an enormous tax because
uh the the the challenges ahead and the
difficulties that many of these people
are facing right now uh are enormous but
also what we've been seeing in several
cities across this area that the work
has started debris has started to be
removed we were in the city of
where there was lots of work inside the
city to clear the millions of of rubble
that is scattered all around this area
Rubble dust and loss are everywhere in
Southeastern turkey these days
authorities have already started to
clear the rubble
but nevermind says she cannot forget
what she has lost and comes here every
day where her home once stood
we removed my mother and father from the
rubble only my father was alive every
day I come to the same place to see if I
can find their belongings just to have a
memory
foreign
away the mountains of rubble is a
daunting task because it is everywhere
in this part of the country
trucks have unloaded tons of rubble all
around this area creating these
mountains that you can see right behind
me removing the debris from the center
of the city is a huge challenge
according to the United Nations the
volume of the rubble that needs to be
removed they've all put together would
cover an area of around 100 square
kilometers
or over 18 000 football fields the
Turkish government says the rubble will
be removed and processed without harming
the environment and the people
but environmental groups have expressed
fears about possible contamination
there is also health concerns about the
presence of afetos a mineral that could
cause cancer which was permitted to use
in Turkey until 2014.
this map shows that asbestos was
detected in the areas affected by the
earthquakes
in the city of Hasa patients are showing
up non-stop at this field Hospital set
up by the Indonesian government
many are coming for regular checkups but
others with respiratory difficulties
Dr coronarindawan says the cleanup
process is crucial to prevent disease
people must be uh covered by a
must be given the the mass if there's a
community
surrounding the rumble before they start
to clean the rumble of the cleaning of
the Ramos makes the the test is affect
the people
primarily of the respiratory problem
turkey is struggling to cope with the
scale of the disaster caused by the
earthquakes removing the rubble is only
the first step of the likely many
challenges ahead the government is under
a lot of pressure not only to clear the
rubble to begin a rebuilding process and
to also assist the the hundreds of
thousands of people that are leaving on
tents in the outdoors among other things
it has also launched an investigation
over 600 individuals or organizations
that are also issued around 180 arrest
warrants among Property Owners directors
of construction company because one of
the big issues caused by the earthquake
is that brand new building that we're
supposed to to resist an earthquake did
not and there were completely destroyed
so those investigations are ongoing but
many of the people when you talk to them
they say that they celebrate this
investigations but but they really want
to know is when they'll be able to go
back to their normal lives
okay thank you for that Theresa Beau
there live for us and gazingtep in
southern turkey